varying wind patterns
sea levels being higher than what you're
used to and i'm you know less than 40 i
can i can see differences from when i
was a child
not mitigating co2 emissions
and destroying our biodiversity
we are killing our planet
ultimately
the emergency climate comes down to a
single number
the concentration of carbon in our
atmosphere
the measure
that greatly determines global
temperature
putting a hard number on the economic
impacts of climate change is difficult
it's difficult to say that hurricane
harvey which caused 125 billion dollars
in damages would not have happened or
have been less severe without the
effects of climate change in play it's
difficult to say that the 2018 wildfires
in california which caused nearly 150
billion dollars worth of damage were
caused by climate change it's difficult
to say that climate change caused the
severe cold snap of 2021 which left
millions of texans without power and
cost the state's economy upward of 130
billion dollars but it's not difficult
to say that these natural disasters have
been increasing in frequency and
severity and the reasons for this are
well understood and documented multiple
studies across industries have all
agreed that climate change driven by
human carbon emissions is going to cause
severe economic unrest and that's
ignoring the obvious human impacts of
these natural disasters these extreme
weather events affect the most
vulnerable people in our societies most
we need to address this problem now but
finding ways to accelerate our shift
from fossil fuels has been difficult we
depend on fossil fuels to drive our
economy so
not using them to save our economies is
a catch-22 these intangible economic
impacts are unmotivating to most
industries we need an immediate way to
encourage the shift by imposing tangible
economic pressure this is where carbon
taxes come in taxes that are levied
directly on the source of carbon
emissions but this economic policy comes
with its controversies and problems take
a simple carbon tax that is placed
directly on fuels according to their
carbon emissions the idea here is to
decentralize the use of carbon intensive
fuels
but how would that actually play out at
an individual human level the obvious
answer is that fuel prices will go up
and make it more expensive for normal
people to get to their jobs and heat
their homes
individuals that can afford new electric
vehicles will buy new electric vehicles
but the reality is the vast majority of
people can't afford to make that switch
and electric car manufacturing isn't
producing enough vehicles to allow that
immediate change to happen the people
who struggle most financially will be
pushed even further into poverty on a
larger scale the economic impacts are
harder to predict electricity prices
would of course also be affected our
grids rely on fossil fuel for power and
an increase in fuel cost would be passed
on to consumers but increased
electricity and fuel prices impact every
single industry on the planet a sudden
increase in overhead costs for
businesses would likely cause a dip in
countries gdps as industries adapt
these are serious issues that
governments need to consider and weigh
up against future and often intangible
economic losses as a result of climate
change
there are so many variables we need to
consider when creating policies like
this
they need to be high enough to make high
carbon intensity fuels like coal
really unattractive and forced them out
of the market but they can't be so high
that they [ __ ] the economy what
should the revenue be spent on should
the money go back into rebates for lower
economic classes that are going to feel
the pinch most or should they be used as
a tax swap for corporations to reduce
the drop in gdp
today we're going to examine these
questions with the help of two computer
models and the work of mit researchers
who combined the two models to predict
the future under various taxation
scenarios
the models used were the re eds model
developed by the u.s department of
energy to simulate the electric grid and
the usrep model developed by mit which
simulates the electric grid's effect on
the u.s economy combined these computer
models allowed the researchers to make
predictions on how different policies
would affect not just the electrical
grid but the us economy as a whole and
the results are pretty fascinating two
starting scenarios were tested starting
in 2020 the carbon tax would start at
either 25 per ton of co2 or 50 per ton
of co2 so how does that work how do we
measure co2 release one way we can do
this is by taxing fuels according to
their carbon dioxide emissions per
million btu which stands for british
thermal unit and i refuse to use it so
let's do a quick conversion to the big
boy pants scientific unit of joules
which more or less equals 1 gigajoule
plus some change one gigajoule of coal
is only about 35 kilograms of coal
maybe two bags of your traditional home
heating coal coal emits about 0.1 metric
ton of carbon dioxide per gigajoule if
we priced our carbon tax at fifty
dollars per metric ton that would result
in five dollars of additional cost
however we can see that natural gas
releases about half the carbon dioxide
that coal does making its penalties half
that of coal and thus giving it a major
advantage in the market
next these studies applied two annual
rates of carbon tax hikes
one where the tax would increase by one
percent a year and one where it
increased five percent a year combined
this gives us four scenarios
let's see what happens in these four
scenarios
the electricity price projections from
2020 through 2050 for each scenario
looked like this unsurprisingly
electricity prices jumped in all four
with the initial spike being entirely
determined by the starting tax of 25 and
50 dollars per tonne of co2 but despite
the tax increasing by one percent or
five percent every year the prices do
not continually increase
the electricity grid adapts and evolves
to the new tax environment very quickly
with the most aggressive tax policy the
initial price spike is 50
a very large increase which decreases to
30 percent by 2030 and then decreases
again in 2040. these price increases are
daunting but it's incredible to see how
this simulated electric grid adapted
this is the energy generation projection
for the entire us under a no tax
reference case coal natural gas and
nuclear provide the brunt of the
country's energy with the only major
drivers for change being cheap wind and
solar increasing in generation and being
supported by rapid response natural gas
power plants
both eating into coal's percentage
30 years with only a minor increase in
renewable energy however this is what
happens under the high tax scenario coal
is immediately and unceremoniously
heated from the electric grid its high
carbon intensity power becomes
completely unviable within only a few
years the coal power plants are
throttled out of existence while natural
gas power plants and wind energy quickly
take over the void left behind
solar energy gradually increases in
capacity but the study does mention that
the mix of solar and wind is highly
sensitive to assumptions made in the
model most interestingly in this high
tax scenario
a completely new type of technology
appears around 2040. with that 50 carbon
tax increasing by 5
every year the carbon tax in 2040 in
this scenario will be 133 dollars per
tonne of co2 and at this stage it
actually becomes economical to combine
natural gas with direct carbon capture
direct carbon capture a technology that
absorbs carbon dioxide directly from the
air currently costs between 250 to 600
dollars per ton it's nowhere near cost
effective but that price is expected to
continue falling and it will be a lot
cheaper to extract carbon dioxide from
the exhaust of a gas turbine than trying
to capture it after it's diluted into
the atmosphere and say by 2040 we
managed to get the price down to 100 per
ton
combining this technology with natural
gas plants will make a lot of sense and
that's 33 dollars of cost savings for
every ton of captured carbon dioxide
what's truly encouraging is that under
this scenario carbon dioxide released
drops by over 90 by 2050. if we plot the
other tax scenarios on this graph this
is what we get the big takeaway from
this particular graph is that the 25
at five percent growth is more effective
long term than the 50
at one percent which makes perfect sense
as the high growth 25 tax overtakes the
low growth 50 tax within 18 years
this plays out with our emission
projections too with emission reduction
stagnating for the one percent growth
scenario they just about managed to
offset increases in emissions from
economic growth which is not enough it's
clear a higher rate of increase of five
percent is needed to encourage rapid
responses from industries
all four scenarios resulted in cold
dying it seems the magic number to make
that happen is around thirty to forty
dollars per ton of carbon dioxide and in
every scenario eliminating coal is what
drives the major drops in carbon
emissions and we absolutely need to
prioritize getting it out of our energy
generation mix
so what actually happens to all that
money raised this graph shows the
revenue raised under the four different
conditions with the high tax high growth
scenario raising over 600 billion
dollars what should we actually do with
this money it doesn't just vanish
this study examined three primary ways
to recycle the money raised to offset
the negative effects of the tax
lump sum rebates to households affected
by the carbon tax labor income tax
reductions and capital income tax
reductions along with five hybrids of
these three potential tax pathways
they found that direct returns of the
money to households is the most
progressive meaning it minimizes the
impact to low-income households however
they found that direct capital tax
reductions are the most efficient for
maintaining the economy it's essentially
a tax swap any money raised from the
carbon tax is just used to reduce
capital gains but this is the least
progressive policy favoring richer
households
the best policy seems to be a hybrid
system where six to eight percent of the
carbon tax is recycled to low income
houses while the rest goes directly to a
tax swap with capital tax
this seems like a happy medium between
progressivity and economic efficiency
it's clear that carbon taxes work
straight taxation of the fuels is the
easiest to understand but places like
california have implemented cap and
trade systems that put a hard cap on
carbon emissions with allowances to
different companies
companies that manage to reduce their
emissions can then trade that allowance
to other companies that need it this is
a much harder system to keep track of
however as there is no easy way to
monitor companies emissions across
activities and we have seen with high
profile cases like volkswagen's emission
cheating technology that was fitted to
11 million vehicles the companies are
willing to find ways to cheat these
systems if possible a direct tax on
fuels is impossible to cheat
this system works it forces polluters to
adapt their business quickly it causes a
radical reduction in carbon emissions
and encourages innovation many countries
are implementing carbon taxes and are
gradually ratcheting them up but the
united states is not one of them in fact
the fossil fuel industry is still
benefiting from massive tax subsidies
while their own lobbyists fight against
carbon tax with the high iq argument of
taxes are bad
no one wants to pay more taxes but the
reality is this tax can be implemented
and result in no extra tax revenue being
raised it just shifts where the taxes
are being pulled from and encourages the
shift to low carbon energy and that will
save us millions of dollars in the long
run from reducing the impact of climate
change on our planet
this is one of the few videos we've made
where we focused on a single study
videos like this can feel really dry
just filled with data and graphs we've
tried to make subjects like this as
interesting as possible because it's
incredibly important that this
information be publicly known and
understood part of making it interesting
is by making it visually stimulating but
there is only so much you can do with a
graph in 2d motion graphics before it
starts to feel like a high budget
powerpoint presentation investing in our
3d animation capabilities was our
biggest goal for 2021 and i think it's
paid off allowing us to create our
little virtual real engineering office
in blender where we can place models of
the machines we talk about and leave
easter eggs scattered around the room
that the vast majority of you never
notice
most importantly it allows us to make
the raw data we talk about a little more
visually interesting
blender is a free software that anyone
can use but it can be a little bit
daunting to learn a new program like
this
luckily there are excellent classes on
skillshare for all your blender needs
whether you are looking for the skills
you need to bring your engineering
design concepts to life with beautiful
realistic renders or want to create
colorful cartoonish animations
skillshare has a class to teach you all
you need to know this is just one of
many learning paths on skillshare from
creative skills like photography and
video editing to productivity skills
like project management and habit
formation
so whether you are interested in making
a career pivot or up leveling your
skills in your current role for 2022
skillshare is a fantastic resource to
help you learn new skills to support
your passions the first 1000 people to
use the link in the description or press
the button on screen right now will get
a one month free trial to join
skillshare's growing community of online
learners
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now you can watch your last
video on the incredible engineering of
the james webb telescope or watch real
science's latest video on the material
properties of spider silk